hey I'm Eric Andre and this is my shitty
dating advice from a man who should not
give any advice about anything okay my
boyfriend and I have been together for
about six months and have a fantastic
relationship we are very open with each
other and our good friends as well as
partners age 23 and 24 how do I tell him
I love him without completely freaking
him out just say I love you or maybe
double freak him out go and shake them
be like don't you understand we're gonna
be together forever I am the worst guy
to ask advice about this I'm an
emotionally callous sociopath I'm not
sure whether this girl likes me or not
every time I hit her up or call her
she's busy working manager or going to
school full-time and I never get around
to taking her up hmm how do I get around
this do I not talk to her and go on to
the next level advice please my first
word of advice nowhere to use
parenthesis I don't understand manager
and full-time speak English doc I ain't
a [ __ ] scientist she doesn't want to
[ __ ] you sorry to be so blunt but no
one's that busy busy is the oldest
excuse in the book cave women would say
they'd be like oh I'm busy I got these
rocks to grind into Little Rock's kind
of coming off like an [ __ ] I'm sorry
you know what I'll [ __ ] you no condom
I'm only 17 and I live in the
Netherlands I'm crazy about my best
friend I seem to sense some kind of
connection but all her friends say that
she just doesn't see it that way
however she once said she had thought
about us in a relationship if I were to
be given the chance to be in a
relationship with her I'd be the
happiest guy in the world she is 16 and
I'm 17 please any form of advice would
be very appreciated you're in the
Netherlands you guys have got great
ecstasy out there maybe just see both of
you pop Molly's and see where that takes
you what if you guys still don't make it
work if your love doesn't blossom after
that
to serotonin machine-gun blast away in
your brain probably not meant to be I
have recently started dump to school and
have since become very interested in one
of my classmates she is really neat and
seems like a good fit for me the kicker
is we will be spending essentially every
day for the next four years together and
will have the same friend group because
of that if we were to start dating and
something went wrong we'd have to live
with it until at least 2018 so I'm
asking for some friendly advice on how
to approach this hey man
fill her cavity you know what I'm saying
bro I remember when I was in high school
I was like man I don't want to date
anybody from high school because then if
I break up with them I'll have to spend
the next four years with them I got a
date chicks from different high schools
but I wasn't meeting chicks from
different high schools I wanted meeting
anybody so I was an idiot alright last
one in this hetero dominant society I
always see quotes such as if he really
wants you he'll come after you or
whatever variations but as a gay
individual in that context I the him to
chase or am I the person in waiting all
of my gay friends get laid more than any
more than Wilt Chamberlain more than
anybody I know just go outside just go
to a porn shop or a gay bar and you will
be like a few minutes before you're
getting your dick sucked see you in hell
and Landers is that a person see in hell
and Landers whoever you are